So essentially, what the reference count and
the existence guarantee is giving you is, it
is giving you the same facility, without
doing the hierarchical locking, that was what we
really wanted. What we really wanted in
this hierarchical locking is the existence guarantee of
this process object to guarantee the integrity
of this object. We're getting that. We're getting
that by associating a reference count and making
sure that this particular object is not gotten
rid of until the reference count goes to
zero. So we're achieving the effect of hierarchical
locking without losing concurrency for operations that can
go on in parallel. Of course if these
page faults for T1 and T2 are accessing
the same region of memory, you have no choice
except to go to the same region object. But there
again, this is something that the operating system can monitor
over time and see if, even though it is the
same region, maybe this region itself can be carved up into
sub regions and promote concurrency. And the limit, you can
have a region for every virtual page, but that might
be too much, right? And that's the reason that you
don't want to have a detonation of a page table into
such a fine grain partition. But you might want to think about what is the
right granularity to promote concurrency for services like this to go on
in the multiprocessor. So coming back again
to the hierarchical locking. The key to
avoiding hierarchical locking in Tornado is to
make the locking encapsulated in individual objects.
There's no hierarchical locking. Locking is encapsulated in
the individual object and you're reducing the scope
of the lock to that particular object. So
if there's a replica of this region, then
a lock for a particular replica is only
limited to that replica. And not across all
the replicas of a particular region. That's important,
it reduces the scope of the lock. And therefore
it limits the contention for the lock. But of course it is l incumbent on the
service provider to make sure that if a
particular region is replicated, then the integrity of
that replication is guaranteed by the operating system
through a protective procedure called mechanism that keeps
these regions consistent with one another because you
made a replica of that. Even if the hardware
provides cache coherence, there's no way to guarantee that these replicas
will be consistent. Because they are dealing with different physical memories,
and therefore, it is the responsibility of the operating system to
make sure that these regions are kept consistent with one another.